this okay
uh great so that's what I'll talk about
and this is Joint work with noga who
couldn't come to the workshop so she
would be giving a better version of this
talk if she were here but this is noga
um and the talk today so after hearing a
lot about non-interactive uh proofs and
arguments actually now I want to talk
about interactive uh proofs and
arguments so we have approval and
verifier and they can exchange messages
ideally for not too many rounds at the
end the verifier should accept or reject
the claim is that X the input X
is in some language L and we have our
usual completeness and soundness
properties for an interactive proof we
want soundness against any unbounded
cheating prover so the probability it
can get the verifier to accept is at
most a half
we can bring this down using a parallel
repetition
for an argument the soundness is relaxed
only against polynomial time cheating
improvers they're uniform not uniform
that won't be so important in the talk
today and we can also use parallel
repetition and money but anyway so the
probability of the verifier except
should be negligible no matter what
polynomial time strategy a cheat
improver tries to follow
and their various complexity measures
that we're interested in uh with the
with these protocols so I'm going to
focus a lot on the rounds so we heard
about non-interactive where we have a
common reference string and one message
for today we have many rounds of
interaction and we want the number of
rounds to be small the communication to
be small the verification time to be
small and also I'll get to it we want
the honest prover to run in small time
okay in fact today I want to focus
um on constant round just constant round
protocols for most of the time
okay so I said I want the prover uh to
run also the proof of running time is
going to be important so we're in the
setting of doubly efficient proof
systems or argument systems so the
honest proofer should run in polynomial
time we're concerned with languages in P
okay so unfortunately p is overloaded
for the prover and the class but you
know which one I mean
so the verifier should be super
efficient and I'm going to focus on
almost linear verification time okay so
either n times poly login or n to the
one plus Sigma for some small constant
Sigma
in particular verification should be
much more efficient
um than the decision problem and
actually deciding whether the input is
in the language and the prover also
should be reasonably or relatively
efficient it should run in polynomial
time okay so the running time for
proving is about the same or only
polynomially larger than the running
time for deciding the language
okay so all of that is stuff that you
probably already know and hopefully love
uh what's the question uh for today so
the question is what kind of
cryptographic assumptions do we need if
we want to get these kinds of arguments
so
I'm not talking about zero knowledge at
all today I'm just in the setting of
arguments for languages in p and the
point is that the verification should be
linear time whereas deciding the
language requires some large polynomial
okay so I want these kinds of arguments
with a constant number of rounds
um and an almost linear verifier uh and
efficient honest program so what crypto
assumptions do we need
um
same question
yeah
I mean it's easy in a trivial sense
um
so if you want an argument that is
complete and sound where the honest
prover is allowed to run in exponential
time and the cheating prover is only
allowed to run in uh polynomial time
then you know the verifier just asks the
proverb to invert a one-way function and
if he succeeds the verifier accepts
whatever the proofer is saying so you'll
have completeness because the honest
group are in exponential time you can
invert the one-way function and you'll
have soundness because the polytime
cheating crew for camping with the
one-way function but it's sure but this
is still a quite multiple object it's
like we don't know if one eclipses are
by when it functions maybe less
it's not uh I think it would be implied
probably by our average face hardness
we need to sample the yeah okay so I
don't want to go beyond the you know
below the existence of one-way functions
so for me it streams
it's a good question okay so what do we
know in terms of using photography
um to get arguments
um for languages in p the classic result
that people have talked about today is
Killian's result saying that using
Collision resistant hash functions you
have a protocol with two rounds or four
messages
but the communication can be as small as
you know polynomial and security
parameter the protocol is doubly
efficient it can work for any language
in P or if you want to go beyond P you
can even get it um for languages in NP
when the honest proofer gets a witness
for membership
so uh what more can we ask for once we
have such a result one thing we can try
to reduce the number of rounds and we've
heard a lot about that but what I want
to ask is you know what happens if we
don't want to assume Collision resistant
hashing right I know that nowadays that
seems like a very mild assumption but
still it's a serious assumption the
minimal assumption in some sense for
some variance of cryptography is the
existence of one-way functions right so
what can we do only assuming the
existence of one-way functions or
equivalently using
um the work of the Orem young a
universal one-way hash function which is
an object we'll get to what kinds of
argument systems can we construct okay
so that's the
the question for today
and the new result I want to tell you
about is that assuming only the
existence of one-way function we show
that any language with a is this showing
or not sure okay any language that's
computable by polynomial size uh by
polynomials by a family of circuits a
polynomial size and linear depth up to
linear depth
um
I don't want to talk much about
uniformity but the circuits have to be
uniform in particular log space uniform
every such thing every such language has
a constant round uh double efficient
interactive argument okay only assuming
um the existence of one-way function if
you want to dig a little bit deeper into
the complexity of the protocol for any
desired small constant Sigma you can get
a polynomial number of rounds in one
over Sigma
um and the communication and verifier
time are almost linear in the sense that
they are n to the one plus this
arbitrarily small constant
um and the prover uh the honest pooper
runs in polynomial attack
so just assuming one-way functions if
what you're interested in is linear
communication or almost linear
communication and verification you can
get a linear depth circuits in a
constant number of rounds more generally
if you want to know what happens for a
general depth D circuits the
communication and the verification time
scale linearly with the depth
new result
um
do we know that any
questions
yeah so I'm going to talk about gkr on
the next slide but
um I don't okay so
we certainly don't know such a result
information theoretically the result we
know about the number of rounds scales
with the depth of the circuit
um why don't I bring it up because it's
on the next slide so this is what we get
and the result of gkr the shopping yeah
it's unconditional so there's no
assumptions made but the number of
rounds rose linearly with the depth of
the circuit and Lafayette is asking can
you hold to get this result
unconditionally
I don't know the answer I think it's
unlikely so one thing that guides me
when I'm thinking about this is for many
of the problems for which we have
unconditional interactive proofs getting
a proof system with really large
soundness error is Trivial okay so if
you just want to get soundness Era like
one over the circuits so probability of
catching a cheating over one over the
circuit size that's trivial
um the point is getting you know
constant soundness or a smaller
soundness and I don't know
unconditionally how to get any soundness
error
um without paying
um a number of rounds that's linear in
the depth okay so it's an interesting
question I mean you could formulate a
conjecture about the power of
interactive proofs that says you know
this is hard or like you could take it
to alternating computation if you look
at it from a complexity theoretic
perspective
and phrase a conjecture there and I mean
I don't think it's known unconditionally
I don't think that it would make like
the polynomial hierarchy collapse or
anything like that but I think it's
unlikely that you'll be able to reduce
or I would be very surprised if you
could unconditionally reduce the number
of rounds beyond the circuit depth below
the circuit depth
yeah so the verifier time uh is
verifier needs to read books
[Music]
um
so the number of rounds is two or four
messages
the communication becomes a security
parameter
also independent of the depth this works
for any polynomial type computation
um
so you just wrote the prover time is
poly in the circuit I mean gkr you can
make it very tight right
yeah
I think the problem I mean I'm gonna go
out on a linear and say that uh getting
it to be
that's circuit size to the power one
plus Sigma is going to be easy using
those results and I don't know about
like really linear time
foreign
online model
um
I don't
yeah I don't I mean
um
I don't know I mean usually we talk
about offline online for the verifiers I
don't think there would be a big
distinction for any of for any of these
results
I think so but you know we we didn't
work out the details and these things
can be tricky so I'm going to conjecture
that the answer is yes but we actually
didn't uh
and then you know yeah you want this
enter the sigma that appears here and
here to be probably one percent
I think yes but yeah
so when you say have a stable size or a
certificate
size
I'm just assuming it's polynomial and if
I showed you the prover time then it
will come in the program the verifier
doesn't care about the circumcise and
that's the sort of the point
foreign
[Music]
for that we have to start with this uh
with this picture that's been traveling
around for a while
um so I want to give the overview an
overview of how the gkr protocol works
and then we'll see the result is based
on the gkr protocol so let's start with
that so we have our computation that's a
big circuit so the width of the circuit
is some huge polynomial like n to the 10
but the depth is small it's only D and
it's a Boolean circuit with fan into uh
with fan in two gates
and the way that you care about uh works
is we take every layer of the circuit so
we fix the input X that's in the bottom
layer layer layer D we call it
we look you know once the input is fixed
every gate in the circuit gets a certain
value zero over one up to the output
gate which suppose the output is claimed
to be one the input X is in the language
and now we can look at each layer of the
gate that's a a Boolean string basically
a string of the values in those units
and we can encode it using a high
distance error correcting code in
particular we use a low degree extension
um and the way the GTR protocol works is
we look at this view of the circuit we
encode all the layers and then we have
what we call this um consistency
sub-protocol that starts at the top with
a claim about the output layer of the
circuit and sort of unwinds the
computation from one layer to the layer
below it okay so we start with a claim
about the encoding the error correcting
encoding of layer I a w i is the the
values in layer I we have the encoding
of the I flare at some location RI that
has been fixed by the previous rounds
that's claimed by the prover to have
value the encoding is claimed to have
value VI
and if if this is uh we reduce this
claim uh or verifying this claim to
verifying a claim about the next layer
layer I plus one whereby reduce I mean
if this claim was true then the honest
group of following the protocol will
arrive at a new claim about a lower
layer in the computation that is true
and if the claim was false then with
high probability over the verifiers
coins the claim that we arrive at will
be false
so that's the soundness guarantee of
this uh consistency sub protocol and
then once we have that the pro you know
the the GK protocol follows naturally we
just do this iterative right we start at
the output layer presumably the cheating
prover is making a false claim about the
output layer and we unwind we use this
consistency protocol subprotocol to get
a claim about layer two and then about
layer three layer four all the way down
until we get a claim about the input
layer
and the input the verifier can just
compute by itself one one coordinate in
the low degree extension or some other
encoding of the input and verified
approver is playing okay so that's
wonderful right hopefully you all are
really excited about that but uh the key
point is that we need to do it
iteratively right we have this false
claim about the output and then we run
this protocol we get a false claim about
layer two and then once we have that
false line we can run the protocol to go
from Layer Two to layer three okay but
it's iterative so it's iterative it
sucks we need at least D rounds and in
fact you need D times
depends on what variant of gkr you use
you can actually do this sub Pro this uh
sub protocol for going from layer to
layer and a constant number of rounds
but certainly you need at least order D
rounds
so that's not going to work for us we
need a different idea we can't just
parallelize at least not trivially uh
the gkr protocol and the idea is going
to be to try to first get the approver
to commit to all of these encodings of
all the layers and by commitment here I
mean something that is binding so a
locally openable binding commitment I
don't really care about hiding today
so the first thing we're going to ask
the prover to do is to commit to all of
the layers all the of the layers right
the values of all the layers are known
to the prover in advance once we fix the
input all of the layers the values are
fixed we can ask the prover to commit to
all of them
okay just try to hold on in your mind
and not worry about exactly how I'm
going to build this commitment or what
it's doing but the idea is ask the
prover to commit to all of the layers it
sends over D commitments
but it sends it all of them in parallel
okay so we're paying the communication
but we're not paying many rounds
and what we want to do
um and I'll tell you in a minute how we
do it is in parallel to check all of
these commitments and we want to catch
the prover if there's some layer I where
it sent a false commitment to the ike
layer but a correct commitment to the
layer below it layer I plus one so
that's I want in parallel for every eye
to check whether this is the case and
catch the proof or if it is
okay
and the point is that the verifier on
its own can check
sort of ask the approver to open the
commitment to layer one see that it's
really a commitment to you know the
that's just the output gate of the
circuit so it's a commitment to the
value one and the verifier can also
check the commitment to the input layer
right that's just the input it can run
in almost linear time in compute
assuming we have such a commitment and
compute the correct commitment so the
approvers has to be lying about the
commitment to the output layer and it
has to be telling the truth about the
commitment to the input layer so
somewhere in between it's going from a
false commitment about a a layer about a
top layer to a true commitment about a
layer below it so there exists some I
where hopefully we can catch him
so how do I want to do that so this is
all we care about now we know there's
some place where there's a true
commitment and a fall there's a false
commitment and a true commitment right
below it
ideally you know what I would want is
use something like the consistency sub
protocol
so arrive at a situation where I have a
false claim about the encoding of layer
I
and then you know reduce that to a false
claim uh run the consistency it's a
protocol reduce it to a false claim
about layer I plus one okay so if I have
a false commitment I would send me a
false commitment about layer I I want to
get from that a false claim about the
actual encoding of layer I and then run
the consistency so protocol
to get to a false claim about the
commitment of layer I plus one but in
layer I plus one he sent me the correct
the correct commitment so we can't open
it to a false value
and now I'll catch it now I'll catch the
approval okay so send me a false
commitment about layer I plus one I'm
going to ask it to locally open so I
need a locally openable commitment to
locally open the value that it's
committed to in the I plus one player at
the location that I'm interested in
and then I'm going to catch
yes something bad happened okay
so
why is second privilege security yeah so
that's uh sorry I'm I I'm afraid to go
back because then it goes back the whole
slide but ignore it don't see it for now
do you have a question mark okay so the
point is and and now kind of the if you
get anything from The Talk today this is
a I mean other than the result this is
an important point to get
all I assumed or all I needed to catch
was a situation in which the proofer
sent a correct commitment to layer I
plus one now the value of layer I plus
one is fixed in advance once we fix the
inputs to the protocol
the True Value at layer I plus one is
fixed
and he sent me the correct commitment to
that layer so all I need is a hash
function where you can't locally open
you know you can't uh break the
commitment with the local opening for a
string that was fixed in advance before
the hash function was chosen
so all we need is a second pre-image or
targeted uh Collision resistant hashing
and that's why we can hope to use
Universal one-way hash functions
um that can be based themselves on
one-way functions okay that's a key
point where we're replacing Collision
resistant hashing
with something much weaker
[Music]
yeah I'm going to have it as an open
question at the last slide
um
maybe we'll get to it in the end I don't
have a clear uh answer for you I think
we have this interesting phenomenon
where for all of the interactive proof
of succinct interactive groups that
we've thought about
we can reduce the ram complexity in this
kind of way
um and I think it begs the question of
whether there's some sort of a general
compiler but I don't know the answer
um
where do I get a local area I use a hash
tray with the office and networks
so you don't need hiding for it right
it's only five it's just a hash yes it's
solely openable perhaps
but you don't want to call the house I'm
happy to call it a house is that what
people call uh
I certainly don't want to hiding
properties so you can even call it
whatever you want so it's not just
anything yeah
um so you're saying that right here
we are
should understand why one-way function
no you just should understand that
um we are out of no because I mean I
haven't explained uh you know where to
become if it's false you know where we
come with this false explained and we
can reduce to a claim about layer I plus
one but you should get in a I don't know
like a flavor of one like why one of my
functions are enough because first the
input is picked then we send the hash
function and now we're sort of forcing
the proofer in some place to send us a
correct commitment to layer
um
so this is layer I plus one and this is
layer I and we've kind of force the
proofer to send us a correct commitment
uh here an incorrect one here
um this was for something that was fixed
in advance and he's committing to
Strings that are sort of computationally
from the string he's committed to here
it's computationally easy to commit to
compute the strings limitation here so
you can hope that you can catch this
very efficiently
but the point about the important point
about the one-way function is that the
commitment is to a string that was fixed
in advance and that's why I mean I think
it's sort of magical that you know these
Yachts exist in the first place but once
you know we know that it's much easier
to build uh commitments
um
so there's some
good situation for me happens I don't
know where it is and I can just check
all of them in parallel I pay in terms
of communication I pay the circuit depth
but I don't pay in the rounds
um if you can get to this situation
where you have a false claim about layer
I
then
do all of them in parallel if you have a
claim about each of the layers you can
just run
um the sub protocol in parallel for all
of the layers for the layer I star kind
of where this good situation happens you
will catch the tuning groups
[Music]
because we don't have these okay so I
haven't told you how we get these claims
about the
uh yeah so in gkr I have to get the
claim about the iflayer before I can
proceed to layer I plus one
are necessary which
should say they are
there's no is there any hard computation
here
so
yeah sadly say that this implies some
kind of computational hardness
20 percent already so so some kind of
moderate hardness would be interested in
the show called even because everything
here is polynomial time so it seems hard
to extract but where is this something
harder than something else yeah it's
interesting I mean I was gonna
um maybe mention it then but I'll say it
now that if you think about the analogy
Surfers for zero knowledge
there was there are these kinds of
results I mean first there's uh Steve
Henderson that showed in some sense that
non-trivial zero knowledge there is a
one-way function
if you have somebody property but still
I kind of just want to say so
for there are these results versus
the minute you have uh non-trivial zero
knowledge so zero knowledge for a
language where you don't have
statistical zero known
then you have some computational
awareness and I think it's really
interesting to try to start exploring
whether something like that also holds
for argument systems
one one stumbling block we've always had
is that is your knowledge One Way
functions are enough
um for arguments they were not so maybe
here there's a start to kind of uh
like how does it compare to RR
how does it compare to RR so just to
understand maybe you'll ask me at the
end because we're in the middle of the
protocol and I guess in terms of the
results like what is the Nexus there are
two things that make it different for RR
it's a different class of computations
so it's bounded depth as opposed to
bounded space and these are incomparable
also if you look inside the number of
rounds here it's polynomial in this one
over Sigma that is that yeah
yeah
so if you want to talk about it
okay
um Okay so
I still haven't told you how we get in
parallel false claims about all of the
layers I okay so I need to do that I'll
do it in a minute I just want to focus
home in for a moment on the properties
we need from the commitment so we only
needed binding for the correct
commitment of the I plus one player in
the circuit
um so the properties we need for the
commitment scheme second pre-image
security or targeted Collision or
something like a universal one-way hash
function we wanted it to be succinct
locally openable and based on one-way
function and you can do this uh just by
using Universal one-way hash functions
um in a tree
okay the important thing in case you're
interested in really exploring this
further on your own is you need to make
sure that in every layer of the tree
you're using a new uh you off okay if
you just use the same one in all the
layers it won't work but I think this is
a belarian Rockaway that said you should
use different ones and different layers
of the tree I don't know
um
okay so now what I want is situation is
just to show you or the main question
that we still have is the proofer has
committed in advance it sends it sent
all the commitments to all the D layers
of the circuit and now we want in
parallel for each of these layers to
arrive at a claim about the encoding of
the layer where if the commitment was
false then the claim about the encoding
should also be false and then hopefully
Rachel will be happy
[Music]
so what we want is to translate false
commitments so if approver is sent the
wrong commitment Yi to a false claim
about the encoding of the ith layer and
we want to do these and once we have
such a protocol we'll do these in
parallel
um and we will be done okay and the way
we do this is using what we call a
translation protocol it's an interactive
proof so this is information theoretic
actually the in our construction for
translating the commitment into a claim
about the encoding
um of the committed string
and we want to do this we want such a
protocol that works in a constant number
of rounds
um I want to say just you know
the commitment itself you know maybe
it's good to just before we make things
complicated to keep them really simple
the commitment is just a computation
right we have some
we have some correct string the correct
encoding of the if layer wi and we're
building a hash Tree on top of it right
and this is the root of the hash tree
that should be y i that's the correct
computation okay
really all I want here is a proof system
that gets a claim about the output of a
circuit this is just a hash tree circuit
so we have a claim about the output of
the circuit and we want a false claim
about the encoding of the input to the
circuit
I can use any holographic interactive
proof there are many interactive proofs
that have this property like the gkr
protocol or the RR protocol
and you can use uh in order to you know
translate claims about the output of the
computation to a claim about the
encoding of the input you could use any
of them
and you know maybe if you just use gkr
here the number of rounds will be
proportional to the depth of the hash
function of the circuit Computing the
hash function times you know the depth
of the tree
still you'd still end up with a protocol
here that whose rounds complexity is
independent of the original circuit so
that's already interesting
we're running all of these in parallel
right we're getting all of these y eyes
in parallel so we can run all of these
proof systems in parallel to get false
claims about the encoding of a layer of
you know each of the layers so that
already is interesting but really I want
to focus because the round complexity
would not grow with the depth of the
circuit but rather with the depth of the
hash function
it would already give us a result but I
want to take it as far as I can just to
get a constant number of runs
okay so we want this protocol basically
a holographic interactive proof if
you're into
um if you're into this terminology
yeah so uh actually I'll ask you about
so what's the shallowest Universal
one-way hormone
let's shrinkage the shrinkage has to be
polynomial
because I want a constant depth for the
whole tree so with concentrated it can
be zero
based on something that doesn't give you
pollution resistant hashing I guess yeah
because we can conjecture is to not not
the standard or something randomly
you can do
it approaches
we looked into it there was nothing
super
anyway we will be able to get fonts a
number around using not by just not just
using GTR but using a difference
um
Credit Control
um okay so I want this protocol that
gets
the input y the claimed commitment why
we have a holographic input W will want
to get a claim about the encoding of w
as an output of the protocol
and as usual if the claim is true we get
a correct Claim about the encoding and
if the claim is false then with high
probability uh either the verifier
rejects or we get a false claim about uh
the encoding of the input and we want a
constant number of rounds you want the
verifier to run I guess in time into the
sigma here
um not even you know it's not even
reading uh the entire the entire input
and the way we go about getting this
protocol will look familiar to you so we
want to strip away the layers we have a
hash stream okay so here maybe we have
you know uh you know this is a size uh
and to the hundred and you know we'll
shrink it every time we'll shrink I
don't know by uh
um by Sigma in the exponent so the next
layer will be 100 minus Sigma and the
next will be into 100 minus two Sigma so
after order one over Sigma layers we get
to the output of the circuit and we'll
strip away the layers one by one using a
sub protocol of the form that we already
know and love so we have a claim about
the encoding of one layer and we go from
that to a claim about the encoding of
the next layer down however notice that
here you know
between the layers we have a computation
of the hash function so it's a
non-trivial this is not a constant depth
of computation or anything like that so
shooting this complex hash function and
nevertheless we want to go from one
layer uh to the one below it in a
constant
uh number of rounds
this makes a
I don't know so I guess something we
could do some sort of rebalancing and uh
when you do with formulas but I don't
know
um okay so that's uh what we want to do
and now I have to warn you there is a
sharp transition because I I just
couldn't
um move Noble slides to this format so
actually if anyone at Apple is watching
I apologize that I've deviated from the
Apple uh these are not Apple slides
these are noga slides
um so that's our hash I and again we
want to have this protocol that goes
from an encoding of one layer in the
hash tree a claim about the encoding to
a claim about the encoding of the next
layer uh in the hash stream so that's
our layer subprotocol
we're back we're safe everyone can
breathe again so and the key Point here
is I don't want to think about this
I hope not
at least it would be a dramatic exit
right okay okay so the point is that
um again these computations going from
the inputs kind of the things we're
hashing in layer I plus one of the tree
the next are up this is a complex that's
the complex computation we're doing a
yoff computation here with polynomial
shrinkage so we don't want to just use
gkr or something like it we could use RR
but that's a whole different can of
worms in terms of their own complexity
instead we just think about this as a
batching
kind of a claim okay so along the lines
of I guess we're pretty familiar with
batching from the previous two talks so
really what we have here in terms of the
claim is that there's a claim about the
encoding of these y eyes the outputs of
the hash function
the claim is that if you encode all of
them and you look at the location RI of
this encoding you'll have a certain
value and at these y eyes are all the
outputs each of them is the output of
the hash function
on an input zi in the next layer down
okay so we think about this as kind of a
batching claim we're verifying that you
know this is true and this is true and
this is true this is true and that
there's some Global truth about the
encoding of all of these Yas and then we
can use a batch interactive proof uh
from a previous work
um a different rrr with Ron and Omer
um to get a constant round complexity
and uh polynomial and into the sigma
communication
explore
you can use this all you can use the
small space or directly you would have
kind of an exponential round complexity
and one over Sigma and I want to have
polynomial so that's a downside I mean I
guess this is a good point because we're
this is all I want to say about the
protocol so I'll tell you asked about
the comparison with the double efficient
interact unconditional multiplication
interactive proofs for small space or
for bounded space so one thing is the
bounded state from bounded depth are not
the same and the other thing is that in
that protocol the round complexity if
you want to get communication into the
sigma or something like this plus
whatever the space is
uh you need the ram complexity to be
exponential and even more than
exponential and one over Sigma
credential one over Sigma here we're
getting the random complexity to be
something like one over Sigma cubed
it's kind of like a technical difference
in the parameters okay
now our eyes are the locations so it's
kind of a location in the low degree
extension and you're asking where it
comes from yeah
so
um
our Europe has to try to read your mind
but are you interested in the RIS and
the protocol outside or here because
there are eyes that are sort of internal
here as we're doing the hash tree the
hash tree verification and there are
those external RIS that you might be
asking where we got them from external
you're asking about the external one so
we basically have this whole protocol
that starts with this y I claim about
the commitment and it ends with a claim
about the encoding of the input at some
location and let's call that RR that
we're interested in and that comes from
iteratively running these protocols in
sequence one after the other so we start
with a claim about the it has nothing to
do
with
um the consistency sub protocol that was
being run outside so maybe that's or
it's not the same way that we get them
in the gkr so we're just starting with a
claim about the commitments uh in this
the commitment of this layer we're
running a bunch of interactive protocols
for each of the layers in parallel
and the output of this interactive
protocol that's being run just for this
layer of the circle we're only thinking
about it
that's a claim about the coding of layer
I at a particular location are
and that's where it's coming from so
we're getting all of these locations are
in parallel from protocols that we're
running on the different commitments
that we got so you're going to check the
hours with random or like R is random
that's a property of uh that's a
property of the protocol
um verify by looking inside the protocol
and it makes sense that it shouldn't
so so each one of these lines is a gkr
level in
in the depth there is
so this eye now everything here
corresponds to the depth inside of those
hash trees right okay but if you're
saying that what is the cop what is up
here
ah um it's just that I mean especially
after we don't have bad verification for
um MP General entry statements but this
is you you sort of thinking
um it could have even said for p
essentially it's just a it's a bad
terrification for statements
right like just like given Z1 it's a
polynomial time computation or an N to
the sigma time computation to compute
both the correct y one is
actually I'm lying a little bit because
again that's already a circuit that's
too I mean as it is you know
it's a high depth circuit so it's too
much so you actually need
in the proof you actually shrink this
circuit down by sending the Tableau as
well
um intuitively for each of these eyes
and that's it's something we pay for but
it's I'm brushing it under the rug we do
in fact need bad certification for you
statement yeah yeah so actually there's
a lot of technical work that gets into
really getting the round complexity down
which in particular means you need to
replace these circuits with something
that's in ac0 and you do that by adding
the Tableau as usual
okay
yes
a little bit but that's a detail or
something okay so that's all I wanted to
say
um
basically from when we function we can
build these locally outable commitments
using a yachtree and from that get
constant round arguments
um for depth B and to my knowledge at
least it's the first instance in this um
in this regime of succinct so where
we're focusing on succinctness so we
know how to use one-way functions to get
zero knowledge for example so we know
how to do non-trivial thing in
interactive in interactive protocols
using one-way functions but in the
regime of succinctness of getting you
know doubly efficient proof or getting
the communication and the verification
time to be smaller than the size of the
computation as far as I know it's the
first instance of being able to use just
a one-way function and not a collision I
mean we have results for multi-collision
sorry I should have said it we have
results from previous work for
multi-collision hash functions
um but here we're able to get all the
way down to a one-way function and of
course there are natural open questions
so so can we lose the dependence on D so
can we get an interactive argument for
any polynomial time computation just
assuming one-way functions I think so
fantastic open question can we go all
the way to NP I'm a little bit more
skeptical but I don't know why I'm
skeptical there's not a lot of things I
have a good reason to be skeptical the
reason I'm skeptical is that the yoff
type of guarantee isn't enough once you
go to NP there are multiple reasons oh
okay great it's a more complicated okay
so there is a reason excellent excellent
so that's some motivation and going back
to uh Yvonne's question uh can we show a
general transformation for any
interactive proof or so or for some nice
abstract
um family of interactive proofs uh
essentially showing that uh you can
always replace
interaction with
um by bringing in one-way functions that
would be great
that's all I wanted to say
now we have a break
foreign